では東海ます。
発勝してください。
たさわ三分ダモたわサブダサモサバラハサマサ分ダ
ダサなんがみだサんガチみさなんちゃみ
弾が三
ンガンサラガチി
ംത..രനം
තිരാമി
ධಮ್ಮංಶರಣಾಮಿ
තිമാ
තිരാമി
ティガチ
ി
താമസി
തമരണമി
തിලതി
യോ
たやさんがミതപി
തിരപതേപം
സമാധ
സമയമാ
ദാനിമാസめ
ിസ
みちゃラウラマニカパンサリアムレマニカパンマ
ムラミカパンサミラ
താമസിനは
の
[鼻息]
私は幸せ
でありませんように
私の悩み苦しみ
が
なくなり
ますように
私の願い事
が叶えられますように
私にż悟りの光が
現れ
ますように
私は幸[歌声]
でありますように
私は幸せ
私は主せ
でありませんように
私は
理解します。
[咳][咳払い]
私のしめ
が幸せ
でありますように
私のしめ
[歌声]
の悩み苦しみ
がなくなり
ように
私のしめ
[歌声]
の願い事
が叶えられませんように
私のしめ
にも悟りの怒りが現れますように
[歌声]
が幸せ
で[歌声]ありますように
私のしめ
幸せ
でありますように
私の主生命
が幸せ
でありますように
しれ
ましょうとなります。
生きる
ものが幸せ
でありますように
生きとしてるものの悩み苦しみ
がなくなり
ように
生きとしける
ものの願い[歌声]のが叶えられますよう
に
生きとしける[歌声]
ものにも悟りの怒りが
れますように
生きとしける
ものが幸せ
でありますように
生きとしける
ものが幸せ
でありませよう
生きしける
ものが
幸せ
でありますように
生きとしけるものがありましてます。
生きし
てるものが
幸せ
でありませんように
生きとしける
ものが幸せ
でありませんように
生きとしける
ものが幸せでありますように。
はい、ありがとうございます。はい。
今日はあの弟子中年会
ということで
、え、
共演会自識できるようにあの教会の人の
方々大変申しまして、こっちのこうこう
何ったっけ会場のあったっけさん
。あ、今日はないです。教会、
え、
ないです。
うん。[鼻息]
え、ま、そういう時、え、大変中で来て、聞いていただいた皆さんも
[ため息]
の広告といたします。え、ね、結構かかりますからね。
え、脳みそが
動かなくなるしね。ですから早くお話を
続けて終われたいと思います。今日はあの
テーマが2つありましてね。
え、
少年したら
2番目の手間ってる方々に殺される恐れな
んだから
、ま、両方
、え、世界
、え、これ両方合体して別なテーマに
しようかなという考えもあったんだけど、
そうするとまた自分の提案させてない
だろうという風に言われたらまた困ります
からね。ま、一応ベスベです。ま、結局は
同じで言わね。はい。え、第1番目にこの
あのこの文章あった通りではなくてもう
ちょっとあの私なりに私の浅い頭で理解
できるように言葉入れ替えますよ。
で、
こちらに送る文章そのまま使えませんね。
え、だからまあ
、え、少々入れ替えています。だから、
あの
道は、まあ、一応全部中い文章呼んでみ
たらね、人はどう行ければいいかっていう
ぐらいのことを聞いてるんですね。
ま、そ、そう言うと
かなり
真剣な真面目なになるんじゃ。も日本語で
考えるとただこれ出らないことでしょうと
思っちゃう可能性ありますね。でも私が
どう生きるかよりかってね。
どう生きるがそれが正しくて正解なのかと
ようことは1人1人にとってから大事な
テーマなんですね。
それを無視しないでアリストレスがこう
いう風に言ったことはどんな意味でしょう
かと。ショッカルティスがこんなこと言っ
たらどういうことかともうまたアウスター
でこう書いてますからそれはどういうこと
かとそれでどうするその中でどうすれば
いいか私はとうかねそんなだったら病院に
行った方がか話が早えんでしょうね。
ええ。だから単純にこの言葉が聞く質は
中学生小学生中学生が聞くも私がどうすれ
ばいいというね、
それがすごくずっとった私たちは首で持っ
ていかなくちゃいけない
疑問なんですよ。
毎日毎日こういう風に出てるんだけどこれ
で本当にこれでよろしいでしょうかと。
これでまずいですか?あるいはこれより
ベターな行け方あるのでしょうかと。
あるいは今1年私は自分自身で納得いける
ぐらいで頑張ってきたんでしょうかと。
今日しっかり頑張ったと思ったか思っても
じゃあそこでその前行ってしまったらそれ
でも何かありますかと。
だから寝よりあるいろんな方面で自分が
どう生きるかっていうことをね考えた方が
ええですね。だ、その質問は内がひにせっ
て質問の文章ありましたからね。だから私
はそこはま、それなりのテーマにし
ましょうと思ったんで。だから私はこの
プログラミングyourlife自分の
人生はしっかりプログラムしましょうと
いう
、え、だから副題でね、人は何をして
いけるべきでしょうかっていうことですね
。
え、それから理性的な生き方は何でしたか
と。
はい。進ん
で色々あの何だったっけ
考えるポイントがあるんですね。
自分の死が決定するポイントになります。
かな。ちょっと意味が分からない。私に
たってもで
自分の死を
考えた方がいいです。
じゃあ死ぬ時は今までのレポートはあ、
OKと合格という風になった方がいいん
です。だからどう生きるべきかと
プログラムする人はまず私は必ず死ぬと
いうことをプログラムに入れなくちゃがん
ですね。
それ入れてないんだから即世の人々は
考えるどんな哲学者であろうとも何のくら
ない妄想の話だけで
ギリシアテでもアメリカ哲学者でも誰でも
ね、ま、中国の学者でもいろんなことを
言ってるかもしれませんだけどだから
プログラミングする場合は先ね、私は知る
そこをそのフレース入れてから
プログラムするんですよ。
死ぬ時は大事にした自分の体さえ置いて
おけます。だからこの仕を感謝するなんて
ですね。
[鼻息]
とは一生懸命
体のこと体のこと体のこと
それ以外何も頭の中にないんですね
。
うん。でも死を考えてみると死ぬ時は体
っていうのを役に立てなくなったんですね
。
肉体もって何もできない状態なんです。
だからずっと
体を神殿にして体を拝んで体のために
必死できてきた人があ、これ知てなく
ちゃう
とこれすらショックになりますよ。だから
プログラムする人は人生は
だから人生プログラにするべきっていう
ことは仏田の教えから出た言葉ですけど
プログラムという単語はパリでないんです
。え、その代わりに別ないたくさん単語が
あるんです。
で、
だから
どりでもね、あ、仏教だったら、ま、
どうせ決まって大嫌いな、ま、主と
いうことは至って簡単なんですけど、
しかしプログラムしなさいと
いうのは冒険的な立場なんですね。で、
あの90歳で100歳で
私はこれから人生をどう生きるべきかと
考えて待っていったっても意味がある。
一般的にそうでしょ。皆様方はま死ぬ
そこそこになってくると自分がの家は
どんなお寺でしょうかね。中はどんな
ところでかとがね、大体もう30分で全て
あの世のことは解決できると思ってるん
ですよ。
めちゃめちゃ生きてきたのに日常生活の
ことでも6にできなかった時と
人生は失敗の連続であったりと子育てする
は失敗するわ。会社に行って仕事をするは
失敗するわ。
どこでも失敗だけであ、死亡の世界はま、
たった30分があればえ、まあ30分長い
ね。じゃあ10分で
だからそれは世間のすっごい頭賢い方々の
考えですけど僕は違うことを言ってるん
ですね。
そこでプログラムするのは若い人なんです
。
だからどちらかというこういうこのお話は
ね、ま、小学生の方々には
ぴったり理解できると思います。
だからまず自分が死ぬことプログラムで
1番
トップラインに書いておくんです。
それは最終結論でそこにどんなプログラム
で進むのかと
大体プログラム書く方々知ってるでしょう
。
大体最終的な何を期待するかとこのそれ
考えてそちらにどんな風な道で
アクセスできるのかっていうの答え出す
ために
そうでないとあのプログラムあの
コンピュータープログラムかけないんです
。
最初にどんな結果かそこがないと
いろんな会社のね、いろんなデータ管理、
お客お客様の管理とかいろんなものある
でしょう。今人の健康状態もね、システム
で管理したりするでしょう。例えば人の
健康状態管理するシステム
まず結果で
どんな結果になるのかとだから異常があっ
たらまっすぐ報
すると
異常の中で死んだらこうするとだから異常
はてとこで異常っていうでたくさんなり
ますね。転走たからもうもう事故起こし
ちゃう。あれこれやとかね。
だからそこであ、それだったらこっちら、
これだったらこっちらこれだったら
こっちらこれだったらこちらと
そこをある程度でレイアウトできてから
過ぎ過ぎ過ぎ過ぎ
お客様が個人がデータまでです。
だからこの人生のプログラムの場合でも、
ま、ほとんど同じ状態で増す結果、
え、生きることの結果は死ぬことです。
他何もない。
それでそこを入れてそこでそこを
プログラムしてみると体が役に立てない
機能しない
人やらやら肺やら月石流れ何とも動かない
手足はかない
最悪状態でしょ。その時は
その時苦しいですかと。
苦しくないよ。
その苦しくなるのはこの肉体に対して強烈
な拝借がある時なんです。
これ宝物。これ神様にえ、なんだかさ、神
様がくださったもの。それは何より価値が
あるもの
とか考えているいたなれば
その人が死ぬあの間でまの当たりに自獄を
経験するんです。極限な苦しみを感じるん
です。極限にしを感じるんです。極限に嫌
なことを嫌味を感じるんです。
それで自分で何もできんだから
ものすごく
もう苦しみがどんどんどんどん
だからプログラムするとは死ぬ時は体を
衰えている
気の低下ほ一一部停止一部か。
その時苦しいか。
ああ、ああいう
賢い思考があったならば命が宝物
命にはなんて言いますか
等しい
大事なものありませんと。これ唯一神様に
助けられた。
そういう思考があると
ピシッと自分の前であの死にかけてる人の
前で黒元の苦しみが生まれてくるんです。
だから極限の苦しみを感じた人には何も
思考できない。何も判断できない
で死んじゃったら同じ次元に行っちゃう
です。
他何を選択できんだろう。
だから即世間では
いは大事なものやと言ってるんだから、ま
、商人にはちゃんと死合時刻に行くという
道が確定していれいます。嫌な仏の話を
聞くならば
命ってゴミやと。
執着ない
だったら別に呼吸はできなくなって別に
いいんじゃないですかね。それでは入れ
てるんだから
できなくてる人にまた元気になるわけじゃ
ないしこれからマルトン走るとこはないし
だからできなかったら色々く入れて入れて
やってるんだからね。
ですよね。いるんです。
あと何時間ですか?あと何時間ですかと
計算しなきゃな。
お祝いの来た人とはでは明日来まって言っ
たってもああそれはまあ生けてればあの話
でねどうでもいいやとやって挨拶できれば
明日まで持てるか分かりませんよ。
[咳払い]
そういう人々はいつだって明るくて頭が
しっかりしていて
選択があって
もしかかに愛着があったならばますごかっ
たらどうしようと
で心配があったらあにすごくいいことに
いい次元のこと考えちゃうんです。
そこで再加速知識気づいてきた人間関係、
業績、メダル、トロフィーなどの1つも
あの世には持っていけないんですね。
だから何やってきたのかと。
人がここでトロフィー取ったからて言って
死亡の世界で
特別扱いされる
目とったからて言って目とってもね20代
でねその人が60代70になってくとあの
メドルも役に立ててないね。
どこかで置いてるだけで
埃りを吹いてみたらまあそボロボロになっ
ている。
いうことで
仏教的には
そういう何1つも持っていかないってこと
プログラムちゃんです。
私は死ぬその時一切何も持っていけない
です。
だからこれが初に書いているのはブダの
言葉はちょっと現代日本語にしたんです。
何も持たす生まれて何も持たす行くと
それちょっと日本語文化に合わせた3番パ
がた番なんでパーリ号にあるの
それは学者にた訳してもらうと何のも役に
立てない日本語になるんです。
で、3
番と海がタでちょっと文格的なフェだからこういう風に覚えてください。
何も持たず生まれて
何も持たず行く
何も待たずにです。え、待たずに何も
ああ
[笑い]
大変なことになりました。
プログラムにバが入ってますから直します
。
これでいいんじゃ。て大丈夫?
持たす。最初の方です。
最初の方
またあるです。
ずれで大丈夫です。
うん。
あ、
はい。これで停してしまった。
このフェイスを覚えておきましょう。
この間試験が決めたプログラムで奴隷の
ように必死に
ええ奴隷のように死ぬで働くです。
はい。これでなんか
シト座りますね。
命にはプログラムありますよ。
それはどうすることもできないのに、
この世間の人間が
心理はまっきり知れない。直見の夢は自分
たちがプログラムです。
我々はそのプログラムに強引に
抑えられてるんだから
生まれたきた人は死ぬまで奴隷なんです。
学校に行けなくちゃいけない。決まってる
こで勉強してなくちゃいけない。まあそれ
なりになんとか入れてくれた会社に行か
なくちゃいけないわ。ま、結婚しなかちゃ
いけないわ。あれや、これやとがね。
全部決まってるものでしょ。結婚したら
どこに届けするのかとか子供がどうするの
かとかね。
何か何で世間が決まってるんです。
例えば結婚登録しないで2人が一緒にいて
、え、その人はじゃあ俺のさ、私は先に
死んじゃいますからお前ってくださいよと
。
それは正直ね、あの奴隷のプログラムに
入れておかないと。
そうそろと政府が出てあんた赤の足りん
でしょ。
だから信頼との親戚は地球を回って下げん
です。
できれば銀河系の中でも下すことです。
誰かそうそこその成績がいるも書いと
なんで自分で一緒にいた自分お互仲良くし
た色々お互いに協力してた人をねじゃあ
あんたこれ買っちゃえと言えないんです
ですから世の中で無数のプログラムてこの
1つももう超知識人が超理性のある人救っ
たプログラムではないんです。
全て持ちない人々ったプログラムなんです
。そこでどれになって働いたからと言って
何のこともないんです。例えば教育
プログラム、教育システムムっていうのは
決まって知識人がやらなくちゃあかん
でしょ。
ではそれの教育プログラムにはまって素直
に勉強したからと言って
なんかいる?
あ、たまに成功する人いるんだよと。でも
失敗する人の方が多いでしょ。
はい。マーケティングやらビジネス
マネージメントやら経済学やらこういう風
の学んだ方が自分の商売始めて奥番長に
なれるとほんでにそう
ビジネスマーケティング
イコノミーあれこれやったからて言って
それみんな成功するわけないでしょ。
だから1万人の1人が成功しまったという
プログラムが正しいプログラムですかね。
1万年に2人が失敗と言うならば
プログラムは正しいです。
だから世の中全ての政義社会経済あるいは
これというあらゆるプログラムの中で
病院見ましょうか?これ病気を直す書
でしょ?本当に直せますかね?
どこかで体の中で異常があったらそれを
切って張ってそれ程度ぐらいでしょ
おできるだから病気を直すこと全くできない量ステムでしょ。そこで乗るのは大人間っていうのは病気になっても病気を直すぐらい持ってるんです。
だから我々毎日いろんな病気にかかれます
。
でもそこなります。
で、こちらに来る時、私もこ、あ、前
すごく調子が悪くて
頭が動かなくて
、もう
どうしようもない状態でいたです。何れも
やった。
で、これ大けで行ったらだ、それから後で
みんな腰持ってくると思いますよ。に死ぬ
という
そういう風にこの頭行かれてるこの変な
プログラムでね、ま、私の色々これ飲ん
だら治ります。何が治るの?こういうこう
いう病。あ、そう。こんな俺ないんだけど
と言えないんだからダめてありがとう
ございます。
だって言ったって理解しいないんだから、
あの人頭でコピりでこの暴則はこんな病気
で止んでるんだよと。
だから言っても意味がないんです。はい。
それを置いといて我々は死ぬまで奴隷で
生きているんです。
とりあえず理解した方がよろしいです。
早速きます。
で、今プログラム2つと考えたんです。
だから奴隷になってるのは社会の
セクションなんです。
他の人間と生きてる場合はどれです。
しかしもう1つプログラムありまして
インサイドプログラム。
それは持ってます。これやっぱり
リプログラムしなくちゃあかんないです。
インサイプログラムの場合は1番最初に出
てくるプレスは生きたい。
それで心が動いてるんです。
普通のプログラムと同じです。
ゴールのフレースは生きてきた死にたく
ない。それからその目的達成するために
どうすればいいかと後で小さな小さな
小さなプログラム加えて加えて加えていく
んです
からまずそれ理解しましょう。この生きて
きたし行けたくないっていうのは仏教専門
業でえあるいは活いていうんですね。
賢む人は自分に活があること
です。
プログラム開けてみるんでしょう。
エコーディングは
こ読んでみるとあ、あるんですね。活合っ
て言ったった専門業語だからようわから
ない。これファンクションが生きてきたり
したくないという機能ですね。
それが発見しないと。
そこで一般の糸人は
大体知って歴体死にたくないといえば知ら
ないのはそれがすっぺ
感ているんだと
うちの世界も外
だから2つプログラムあるでしょう。
社会が救ったプログラム。
これは初めてたくさんなる自分の中にある
プログラム[咳払い]
で中にあるプログラムは1本しかないんだ
からどうしようもない。そこはあの起動し
ています。外のプログラム社会が作った
プログラムがたくさんなるんだから自分は
いくつか選んで
それにはまってそちらの奴隷になる。
そこでこの生きてきたということは無意識
にあるんです。
で、誰かがなぜ生けていきたいのか、なん
で死たくないのかと。
え、変でしょ。けていきたいという考えは
なんでそうなるのかなんで死にたくないと
思ってるんでしょうかと。これ徹底的に
調べてみるならばこの無意識のプログラム
が
、え、一般のお手の知識になるんです。
いわゆる取り除けばっと取り除くこと借場
できるんです。
裏でベグラウンドでこと削除できないん
です。
しかしこの生きて死たくなっていう
プログラムこの気持ちを徹底的に研究する
ことは人はやれない。
これは世間ではやってはいけないと
決まってるんです。
だから着用できません。
に感謝してみれば
このベックグラウンドで
裏で隠れて働いていたこのラインが上に
来るんです。
そしたらさが
簡単に最中できるです。
え、そういうことでうちなるプログラムは
あのこういう存在欲で
リスタートする。そこは管理する。それで
勉強していないんだからそこはちょっと
この当てにならないプレスなんです。
あのデータ持って立証できないです。
正しいと活合が正しいかないか立証でき
ない。
データない。
調べる人がこれはあるはない方がいいやと
。これがトラブルだと上がるんです。
割り込んでるフレースなんです。
だからバグですね。で、そのライン借入
することです。
瞑想で我々やらせているのはそういうこと
ですよ。
主義にもう1つ誤解がありまして、生きる
とは体のうであります。みんな生きると
思ったら肉体の意管やと思ってるんです。
てそう思ってるんです。
あ、行けてるんだと何を食べるのか、どこ
に行くのかね。どこに住むのかとかね。
どこに仕事をするのか、どれぐらい収入が
あった方が良いのかとかね、
どんな服買うのかとかね。
レンダー見て気温は何しましょうか?明日
何しましょうか?ライ決何をしましょうか
とかね。やっても肉体の位置管理ですね。
そこで肉体の1管理だけが生きるとこにし
たらみんな大失敗ではあるんです。だせば
死にます。
肉体は昨日低下停止するんだ。
誰も成功しない。
だからプログラム変えなくちゃ。
そこで肉体を維持管理することが生きてる
ことやと思ってるには初義の問題ができ
ます。命に邪魔するものは敵。支えて
くれるものは味方で。これで我々は精神的
に全ての物事は2つに分けてみるんです。
味方と
やられてますよ。
我々にはこの世の中で味方と敵しかないん
ですよ。
だからいかに変なプログラムかて分かる
でしょう。
味方とけ。味方と
それでみんな勉強しないでしょ。この味方
というものをも一定しないです。
共の味方が明日にも味方になる保証はない
です。
今日の味方が明日で敵に回してる可能性
あります。今日の敵が明日に味方回す可能
性もあります。
え、希望の場合は味方がたくさんいたんだ
けど明日は味方は2人しかないとかあまり
ないとことになるんです。だから味方的と
いうこの流れ
だからこれってのは自分が他能生命との
コンタクトなんです。
自分が他能生命とコンタクトする場合は2
つ持ってるんです。味方と敵。
でもそれで2つ、あ、このグループは永久
的に敵。このグループは永久的に味方って
いう風に
定めて落ち着いてることはできないんです
。
ずっと
例えば我々はまあ縦話で言った方が分かり
やすい
石がある
みんなこの石は食べられないと知って
それ定が出るです。
だから悩んです。この石をちょっと磨いて
ピカピカポリシングポリシ状態にしては
あのなんとかあの機械にかけてね主やシや
主やどいは色をけてあるいは何か顔を描い
て色々あるいはおにぎりのような感じで
絵具で描いてとか何にやっても心配はない
お切りのように誰かが上司に
で書いてならば間違って食っちゃえって
いうことはない。
なぜかというと石が食べられないっていう
ことは決定しているポイントなんです。
揺らげない。
だからはっきり白く
揺らがないように設定できれば生きること
はそんな難しくないんです。
証拠では器用は敵やと思っても30分経っ
たらどうなるかわからない。1時間経っ
たらどうなるかわからない。
敵やと思った通りもちょっと何かお願いし
ます。けてくださいというはめにもなる。
だから人は2つのチャルで世間と関係
コミュニケーション取っている。その
チャネルは敵味方というチャルになるん
です。これで困ることは
これが
一定しない。
だから自分がすっごく不安になるんです。
本当に人と話し合ってお茶飲んであだな
いい人だなとはい決定できませんね。
やっぱり心の中ででもよくわからないね。
人のことはどうかね
いうことになります。
だから不安でしょう。
そこで
それ理解れば
あなたは今日は味方ですけどそれから
分からようと
言ったらなんかすごいもう執着にいられる
でしょ。
でもこれ分からないね。このプログラムの
間違い
だから私は新しくプログラム変えなさいて
言ってるんです。
この新しく変える場合は入れるフレーース
今紹介しているんです。
敵と見方という20線で区別ているんだと
。ま、それは、ま、仕方がないとしても
これは一定しないんだと。
だから
、ま、落ち着きましょうと。例えばミスで
現れると泡が、あるいはシャボン玉が
美しく見えますよ。
でも一定しないでしょ。
すぐ弾けるでしょ。だから悲しくないん
です。
シャボン玉が弾けたからて言って楽しく
ない。
でもそれでも楽しかったなって思いばが
もう1度しゃぶんだろです。
でもそれも弾けるです。
だから敵たの流れが一定しないですると
しん玉のように弾けて弾けてあ、あらた泡
が現れてきて
いく流れやと分かる人にとっては執着
しよう怒り憎しむも恨みを持とうっていう
ことは不可能になる。
でも知識人で構成されているこの世界は
どうでしょうか?
執着恨み憎しみ
すっごいでしょう。
もう分かるでしょ?プログラム言語で言う
とどこで間違ってるのかと。
命中を支えるものを支えないものがある
分ける時が分けてもいいんですけど
分けてもえんです。しかしそれは一定し
ない。しゃぶんだもの弾けるんだよと。
だから極限に信頼できる。死んでも死号も
信頼できる味方がいないんです。
死号ももう恨みを持ってる持っていくべき
敵もいないです。
それ分かったら
怒りしと憎しみあるいこ
なくなっちゃうわけです。
ということは
楽チできてるんです。普通に
僕普通に生きてるんです。
風のように生きられます。ただ風っていう
のは我々は何をしてもはかせてきてるん
です。
で、火星よりは水が字が張ってるでしょ。
だから水がドけっとくると困りますね。
このホ路にドけンって水が流れちゃうと
あれ字グ張ってるんだから
で風が吹いたからて別に
なんとこともないんです。
だからこういうプログラム正しく
プログラムコミカ首る人が歌詞のように
はい。次のプログラムの間違いが次にある
んです。この怒りしと憎しみなどの感情が
現れるでしょう。これも間違いでしょ。
方は定められないっていうこと分かって
ないでしょ。
だから感情があるわれたら感情はしっかり
したものやと勘違いするです。感情もその
時その時変化するんだけどね。
それ気づかないんです。
には感情があり決点ね。
それ爆を思うんですよ。自分にその感情
すっとあるんだと。
あの精神的な病気ないでしょ。そうと同じ
感情。あの救ってすってすってき続けて
ますね。
だから常識な人間も同じことでしょう。
感情を持ったらこの感情と続けちゃうって
いうことをするんです。
だからたまに起こったらなぜ起こったのか
というと相手が敵という判断したからなん
です。
味方ではないんです。
え、お茶入れてくださいて言ったら
何や入れません言ったら瞬間でこいつは
できる。
それからその人見るたびに敵という嫌な
気持ちで嫌な人をやって気持ちで見ている
です。
そういうことで我々の間違いで感情を受け
たらそれから感情が
命を支配するんです。
それもうちのプログラムにある大きな
間違いなんです。
感情が言うんです。こうしなさい。し
なさいと
何か物体見たら
あ、これ味方
これは恐な味方
だからそれはプログラムだから分からない
でしょ。だから何か物体めたらおおす
美味しい。私の公物数だと思っちゃう
でしょ。
私のあるわけないでしょう。ある時食べ
たらあ、美味しかったという感じが思われ
たかも。それでこれが私の工物やとなんで
決めたんですかね。そこでは私の幸防だ。
これって結構飲酒してのいい食べるものだ
。言って食っちゃうでしょ。
だからその時食べるっていう行動が命に
必しようかないかっていう判断ではないん
です。
食べるべきでは食べるべき食べるべきでは
ないと判断ではなく感情が指令するんです
。増いなさいと
で、この感情の司令が生きることはって
いうのは肉体一時間管理するでことでしょ
。人間にとっては
肉体管理するために
サポートするか邪魔になるか関係なくなっ
ちゃうんです。
感情が一旦だからやっちゃいます。
例えば戦争に出てく行く人々は
戦争には行けたこないんです。
人を殺したくないです。
しかし人は人ではなく敵だとまず感情入れ
ちゃうんです。
敵なら殺すべきですね。
しかし敵を殺すために
自分の台所であるいはえ、
リビングでテレビ見ながらフムでできる
ことじゃないでしょう。
敵がいるところにいなくちゃいけないん
ですね。
敵がいるところに行ったら
敵を殺されるではなくてゴブゴブで自分も
殺されるということがあるわけですね。
だから戦争に行きたくないです
が、
政府は我々の間違ってプログラムをいじる
んです。
のためにやらなくちゃあかんでしょうと。
我々はそんなに馬鹿されていいのかいと。
我々の歴史がもっと古いんじゃないかと。
我々にはもうすごい優れた武器やらあれや
これやとあるんじゃないんですかと。
行ってあの怖さを抑える。それから政府が
出ていきなさ司令する。
軍隊に早く戦えた。
そうすると社会が決めたプログラムに怯え
て
コノ法律を犯しちゃうとやばい。
だから戦争に行って
戦うことにするんです。
戦車にて買った人はないんですよ。みんな
負けるんです。
みんな負けるんだけどすごするんです。
年間にそれ理解できないんです。年間って
いうのすごいこのなんて言いますか?
すごいこの認識障害なんです。
生命は人間は
戦争で買ったことがないんです。
誰を
どちらでも勝てないんだったらしない方が
正しい
判断でしょ。
はい。そういうことで感情が指導する
理性ではないです。
怒り嫉妬憎しみ恐怖
があって
例えば自分の家がね、まあ木星
木星の家だとしましょう。
のいろんなことが聞け
牧というのはこの運動によってか色々変化
しますから生きも生きてるんだからね。本
だその上にいろんなボード張ってるでしょ
。
だから気がぐにゃくになるとボド一緒に
動くんだから結構
いろんなわけもわからないめ
できない音が出るんです。それで感情に
支配されてる人が
あ、怖いと思っちゃう。
ああ、怖い。
私は1人で
それで恐怖感が出てくるでしょ。
それでやっと誰かにあって、あのね、昨日
もあったんだけどいろんな変な音が家の中
で聞こえまったよ。
そういえば昨いも突然目が覚めたんだけど
夜目が覚めたらいろんな音を聞こえたんだ
よ。と聞いたお母さんもあ、なるほど。
それはおそらく幽霊でしょ。
これだったらあなたは健康がなくなるんだ
よと。あなたの子供が病気になりますよと
。旦那が眼にかかるかもしれません。
これを追い出せなくちゃかんだ。じゃあ
案内してどこかに案内して、ま、500万
人ぐらい取れます。
だからなんでこの世代でそういうこと
起こる?
昔は持ちだからいいんだけど、
今もやってますね。
このプログラム間違いないんですよ。
感情が
支配している
出なきゃですね。家に音が現れたからて
言って一緒におったことはない。たてもう
心霊がもうか体形形見せてもね。あ、
こんにちは。あなたもいるの?
あのね、どこ行っちゃいやて?これは私の
家ながらと話しちゃえばいいでしょ。
ぶっことないんです。
まあ分かりまった。あんたはそきら私は
こちらと
長くしましょうと。例えば身に立たし
たってもあの感情に支害してない人が
そんなことをするんです。500万円は誰
かにあげません。
ほで面白いことはそれで除例する場合は
かなり金額はかかりますけど1たりとも
成功したことはないんです。
でも今に出てるんです。
これって面白いでしょ。
だからいかに我々が生きるプログラムが
はちゃめちゃおかしいのかってことなん
です。そこで感情が指導すると怒りしと
憎しみが欲が強欲が
あなたを管理するとあなたは動物よりも
いかの存在なん[鼻息]です。
動物は最も最もちです。
だからこのプログラム変えなくちゃあかん
です。はい、次に行きます。
はい。次この感情っていうのは悪魔的存在
ですね。
自分の怒り、自分の打ち込み、自分の恨み
、自分の強欲
自分の打ち込み
あくまで
必ず人を復興にするのです。
必ず失敗させるです。
生きる上で起こる失敗、苦しみ、悩み、
落ち込み、傲、髭満、不安、虚しさなどの
などは感情の刺激に依存しています。
だから生きることは大変だとか泣いちゃっ
てもね、勝手にしなさいよと
自分でそって
何言うのかということ言えば失礼な答え
です。正解です。
感情を理性に置き換えるならば生きること
は楽になります。だからプログラム変える
んです。感情が来たら欲が出たらやるぞと
ね。怒りが出たらは安けるぞと。ってこと
でしょ。
ではなくて不正ちゃろ。
そうするともただそれだけで人生は楽に
なっちゃうんです。
はい。そこでプログラミングね。
プログラムされた人がだからもう私は言っ
てインサイドプログラム
これインサイドプログラムがもう
はちゃまちゃ間違ってるんです。だ世間の
プログラムはただの奴隷システムで
社会の式だにした方から出てあんたどれ
だけです。じゃあうちはどうですか?て
言うとうちははちゃめちゃ
だから人は外のプログラム改良することは
そんなに真剣じゃないんです。
うちのプログラムは直ちに改良しなくちゃ
いけないんです。
はい。で生きている人々はあのプログラム
直す場合はね、え、こはあのテーマにも
ちょこちょこっと戻ろうとしてるんです。
我々はどう行ければいいかと。それで
プログラム変えなさいよと私は言ってるん
です。
人がいろんな行いをするんですね。生き
てる。
とにかくいろんな公をして生きてますよ。
国有することもおかないでしょ。
しなきゃ生きていらないいらない。生きて
いられないでしょ。
そこで1つ1番目は必ず行うべきもの。
いくらでもあ、これ
後回しにするとかできません。人間で
生まれたらある行為は必ずやらなくちゃ
いけない。例えば呼吸すること、
ご飯食べること。
これは逃げられないんです。
[笑い]
2番目は選択できる。
誰かやからやらないかと。その場合は行為
はいくつかあってどちらにしようかなと
いう風ね。え、選択できる。
3番目の行為は
決ってやってはいけない。
しかし人は感情できてるんだから。この
決してやってはいけない行為だったら進ん
であるんです。
怒りが出てきたら
やってはいけないことを選んでやろうです
。
浴上が出たら
やってはいけないことやっちゃいます。
は感情の奴隷です。
感情は人生をねじってです。
もう1行為が行いがあるんです。感情を
制御できる方。
それに仏教では先行為と読むんです。だ
から感情って恐ろしいでしょう。我々は
奴隷にしているんです。理性ではなく感情
が指令するんです。
が生まれたら電車で人の体触りなさいと。
これはやってはいけないことでしょう。で
も浴上が出たんだから。浴上がやれやれと
言ってるんだからやっちゃいます。
怒りが出たら怒りがこういう風にやり
なさい。
とても危険でだから
そういうのは感情の司令か本当は決して
やってはいけないことです。それを仏教で
悪行為というんです。というわけで人類が
感情の司令できてるでしょう。だから人類
が悪行為しかやってないんです。
自分やってる講義の中で先行やアルノ
下がったっても見つからないんです。
感情でやってるんだから。
そこで怒り嫉妬憎しみ
落ち込みなど感情コントロールする行為
が全行為なんです。
例えば怒りが湧いてきたらいくらなんでも
相手も人間だからね。色々私も失敗すると
相手も失敗する。ま、掘っておこうという
ことで、それは先行です。
なぜならば自分に湧いてきた怒りを
混乱してたんです。
それが先行なです。
そうやって行為は様子に分けられます。最初に行きます。
はい。え、正しいプログラム、あの、間違った
LINEせ1つ1
つあの、書き換えちゃいけないんです。自分のものに異常にこの異常じゃないんですね。
異常に承着をしないこと。
仮に自分のものだと思いたくなる。
自分の体、加速、財産、所有物なども本当
に自分の希望通りになるのか再び感察して
あげる。
はい。プログラムのフレーースは
自分のものにならない
ことには全く執着しない。
忘れ物のじゃないんだからね。そこで私のというものもありますね。私の体横見ると
あなたの体の希望通りですかね?体っての手でしょ?これ私の加速偉そうに言うでしょ。でも加速は加速の手でしょ。
私の貸すこと言ったっても自分に全く管理
できないでしょ。
こし言ったら反対するんだからね。嫌だと
言うんだから。
こで最ってもそうでしょう。
自分の土地があっても政府になんとか政権
はなくちゃがんですね。お願いします。の
年をさせていただきまと自分の時でしょう
。
なんで政府がそれにけてるんだけ。
自分のだから勝手に売ることできるでしょ
。でき、あんたも3年も税金払ってないん
だから、もう売れ売るならば直ちにこれ
ぐらい払いなさいと。
広いだから本当に自分の家ですかね。
自分の時ですかね。
そういうことで
自分でものじゃないとなんとなく分かる
でしょう。だったら家族であろうか自分の
再散であろうか
自分の体であろうか執着しない方向へ
生きる。それでプログラムちょっと変える
。
で、もっと正しくプログラム変えるならば
自分の体と周りに
全てのもの
なんでったっけ?周りの全てのものは借り
て使用してるものだという気持ちを作り
ます。
え、日本語はちょっとおかしくなってますけど
うん。
自分の彼だと周りにあるもの体と自分の周りにあるもの全て枯れているんです。体が枯れているんです。自分の家は枯れているんです。
有気持ちになると執着が大体
減れます。
なぜならば借りたものは返さなくちゃいけ
ないんです。
そうすると自分には何もないことになるん
です。
所有物質は一切ないことになります。
感情は感染になくならないかもしれません
が、感情の司令より理性を置いておく。
より先はい。こういうことで感情が
こそこそあっても生きるとは理性で生きる
。このホールは借りたものでしょ。
だから一緒なんか壊さないでください。
それだけ汚さないで[笑い]ください。
時間終わったらさっさと帰ってください。
あ、居心地がったんだからね。も聞いてた
んだからこのままいますということ。これ
ありえないね。
じゃあこのまま晩御飯になるまで本呼ん
だりします。気持ちいいや。この方の中と
かね。借りえないね。借りたものだから。
だから一切自分の殻だとも服務も全て借り
たものをやと理解すれば
、えー、それで理ることになります。
それでもたまたま感情が出てくるかもし、
ま、そんなに気にする必要はないんです。
はい。
はい。次、あの、もう正しい
プログラミングネト理性を育てるために
ブッダが推薦した発症度を実践することに
挑戦する。だ、理性育てたいでしょ。これ
は学校に行ったっても理性が出てこない。
お釈迦さんは発症教えてるんです。
発症とは生きることです。これ間違い
ながらやってみたら
も物のことに
あるわけで。
それからこの精神的安定のために人生は
失敗する存在なのです。人生っていうのは
失敗する存在でしょ。結局は知りますから
。大失敗でしょ。生きてたかったの。
だから何度とも
人の魂で監視しようと思わない。
プログラム言てくださいよ。
みんなところで人数の試しで完成しようと
思うんですね。
とってないだから発症は完成しなくちゃがです。
日できることじゃないんです。だから間違いながらこそこそやってみるとすごい早く完成したことになります。
え、昨日夜はの生き方は比較的に良いのだ
という1種で生きてみましょう。
そうするとプログラムは良いプログラムに
なります。ま、昨日やりましょうと間違い
方がますと
それで失敗の悩みないんです。
日よりまし。情報です。
一切の現象は無常で主に変化して別な現象
に変わっていくことを観察する。もう
ちょっと中見てみましょうよ。変化して
変わってくるんです。
1人見てみれば自分の両親が
とめない
とめな行き方に挑戦する。これ大体プログラミングはそれであの終了です。人はそれで生きれてみるんです。はい。はい。
はい。はい。ブッダの言葉で言えば、あの
、こさんに言ったから今日は全部たくさん
教点取り出しましたけど、あのプリスタン
という
協点があって、
こを聞込んでですね、あの人の心の中で
この人が破滅になる不幸に落とし入れる
何があるんの方
で見てみるために特にこが人々は
ものすごく不幸に不幸になってるかそ方見
てきた
だからなんで伊藤が
見る位置に不幸に陥って
苦しみな。それお釈迦様が原因は見わり
ますよ。それは老ブ同人地
やと。これ感情ですよ。だからローブ動
も人地でできてるでしょ。地が決める
でしょ。やるべきこと。だから悪いことに
決まってるでしょう。
これが原因だよとブッダが教えているん
です。はい。
そこでそのことは芸にありますよ。
同毛
ශරීති
た
。
で、これあのちょっと学者の役を入れまし
たけど
私には分からないんだけど皆様に分かる
でしょうね。
豚欲
愚痴は足き心の人を水からより生じたもの
でありながら
身のなった竹のごとに愛する
ようわからん。
え、不幸になる、自己破壊になる原は人の
心に潜んでいるんだっていうことを言っ
てるんです。
だって1人1人のプログラム間違ってる
でしょ。
だから陣地できてるでしょう。
え、これで理性できてほしいでしょ。
地が自分に司令するんだから。
冗談じゃないんだ。だから自分の心に自分
が不行になる原人が潜んでるんです。
[咳払い]
はい。あの芸能意味、私の意味で言います
。
あの
豚人地に指導されて悪い。それは悪い意な
んです。
悪意がある人のここ人が自分持ってる原因
で破壊してしまいましょう。いわゆる自己
破壊になりましょうと。例えば主は竹なん
です。
竹が元気に成長すると鼻がです。
鼻が咲いて種も現れちゃうんです。だ、滝
の花はそんな美しくないんです。
でも鼻が咲く場合はざっと
咲きましょう。
桜な鼻が咲いたような感じで血がいっぱい
鼻が咲くんです。[鼻息]あの色は葉っぱ
とほぼ同じ色だからなかなか人は気づか
ないです。
しかし
竹の
竹が離さたら
竹が知ります。
それであり成長あります。
そういうわけで竹の命を奪う原因が竹から
見れるんだよと。
で、その同じカテゴリーの植物はみんな
そうなんだ。鼻が咲いたら死ぬ。
あのバナナもそうです。
鼻が咲いたらもうったら終わりし。
どう頑張っても
再生できません。
見事に知ります。
だから地で生きていて、豚陣地はある程度
で成果だったら人は終わる。
もう不幸の
[鼻息]
それで全行為または重戦とは地を制御する
行為です。あの仏教でこの先行為しなさい
。優先行いなさって言ってますね。あれは
すごいト人地をお
大なしくするコントロールする行為なん
ですね。
ですから世が散々する行為であっても心に
ある人を刺激するならば先行になりません
。これで世間が言う先行ありますよ。
それはいいことだからみんなでやって
くださいと。で、世間が言ったからと言っ
て世間で押心まで乗せたからと言って
自分の豚人が
減ってないならば選教ではないんです。
だから私はこういう、こういうことやって
新聞でも出まったよと
テレビでも扱いたよとある番組のテレビの
レギュラーで、え、ま、半年間もそうに
問し、え、喋って決まった言ったらでしょ
。自分何か全て
結局人地が増えただけですね。
だったら先行じゃないんです。
はい。
はい。それで、あの、
どう生きるべきかというテーマの話がそれ
で終わりです。
感じ
4時半4
時半時間はそんなに時間かかりますよ。時間で終わりますね。ま、それでもちょっとあの休憩しましょう。はい。それでは
10分ほど休憩いたします。
はい。え、配信の方も1
回、え、切ってまた、え、再度開始したいと思います。ありがとうございました。